usually the best horror films are in
there scares with gradually escalating
tension the following flicks however
jump straight into the scares before the
audience even gets settled in their
seats
many of them are among the scariest
movies ever made in every one of them
both opening sequences that are certain
to have the faint of heart nervously
eyeing the exits these are some of the
most terrifying opening scenes in horror
history it follows as one of the
breakout horror film hits of 2014
everything about it follows seemed
designed to keep the viewer permanently
off guard it's methodical pace mirrored
that of its monster a relentless pursuer
who could appear as anyone and could
only be shaken off by passing the curse
to someone else see everything's ok and
it's terrifying opening we follow an
obviously traumatized young woman as she
flees down a street to the beach and
something else is following her we don't
know what it is yet
we know she scared to death and by the
end of the scene we know is for good
reason some viewers may have been put
off by the movie's ambiguous ending but
there was certainly nothing ambiguous
about its opening a masterclass in nerve
jangling terror split M night Shyamalan
was on top of the world after the
success of 1999 s The Sixth Sense and
after a long rocky stretch he returned
to form with 2016's split this
psychological thriller is anchored by
James McAvoy as kevin crumb a disturbed
man with 23 different personalities plus
an additional one only known as the
Beast
the opening scene illustrates every
team's worst nightmare as a trip to the
mall for three teenage girls turned
suddenly sinister as Crum nonchalantly
takes his place in the driver's seat if
Stephen King's it is widely regarded as
being among the finest of his standalone
novels and it's 1990 TV miniseries
adaptation scared the pants off of many
a 90's child your friends
the opening scene in which young Georgie
encounters Pennywise while looking for
his paper boat in a storm drain is
familiar to many which makes the version
offered by the 2017 adaptation all the
more shocking much of the film's
pre-release speculation centered on
whether bill skarsgård would be able to
live up to Tim Curry's classic turn as
the evil clown monster but that question
was answered definitively within seconds
of the appearance of those predatory
eyes floating in the darkness of the
storm drain it's an opening that would
have been all too easy to mess up but
instead the sequence established a
vicious tone for one of the best horror
films of the year Halloween John
Carpenter's 1978 masterpiece gave birth
to a thousand horror tropes it was a
film unlike anything fans of fright
flicks had ever seen and that includes
its opening sequence which put the
viewer squarely in the shoes of a maniac
the scene leads us through the halls of
a suburban home from the point of view
of an unknown person who dons a clown
mask grabs a huge kitchen knife and uses
it to stab a teenage girl the
first-person point of view is only
broken at the scenes end when the girl's
parents arrive home to find a murderer
standing on their front lawn revealed to
be the victims six-year-old brother
Michael Myers Michael
carpenter would go on to a long and
distinguished career of scaring the
living daylights out of audiences which
anyone brave enough to sit through the
first five minutes of his breakout hit
could have easily predicted cube
released in 1997 cube operated with a
mind-bending sci-fi premise that
revealed itself gradually after a
stunningly effective cold open a man
awakens to find himself in a cube-shaped
room with several apparent points of
exit completely unaware of how he got
there or what he is supposed to do after
finding all exits to be essentially
identical he picks one and goes through
and then
the rest of the film features some
similarly violent scenes but none of
them blindsided us quite so hard as the
first The Hitcher a young man picks up a
hitchhiker by the side of the highway in
the middle of nowhere on a dark and
stormy night that's a pretty spooky
premise on its own but 1986 is The
Hitcher quickly turns it into something
even more sinister with an opening scene
to left audiences with no doubts about
where the movie was going this opening
scene introduces Rutger Hauer Jean
Reiter as an agent of pure mayhem and
how his performance makes his previous
turn as psychotic replicant Roy batty
and Blade Runner looked positively
endearing by comparison of all dead
horror film fans had plenty of reason to
be wary of 2013 soft reboot of Sam
Raimi's classic Evil Dead but those fans
had no way of knowing at the time that
the project was in the hands of a major
Talent writer / director fede alvarez
who made no attempt to rehash what had
worked in the previous series but
brought a wickedly inventive tone all
his own instead the film opens with a
terrified young woman being hunted down
and captured in the woods by her own
family who appear to be religious
fanatics bent on burning her alive but
as her father fumbles with the matches
the woman's tearful please take a hard
left turn and it suddenly becomes
obvious that the only terrible mistake
this family made was not getting that
fire started a lot sooner thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]